[Musik]
direkt neben der leipziger oper ist eine
elektrotankstelle hier parkt vor einigen
wochen hagen kunze sein auto und
schließt das gute stück an die
ladestation an
ein paar stunden später kommt er aus der
oper zurück und hat zu seiner
überraschung ein knöllchen am
scheibenwischer
der grund die fehlende feinstaubplakette
umweltfreund kunze ist fassungslos denn
sein auto produziert keine abgase hat ja
noch nicht einmal einen auspuff
trotzdem drohen 80 euro bußgeld
als ich das auto zugelassen habe auf der
zulassungsstelle meines landkreises
sogar die aussage bekam ich bräuchte
keine grüne plakette habe danach gefragt
und die dame lachte und sagte also wer
wende nicht ein elektroauto ist denn
sonst soll denn sonst befreit sein
hagen kunze glaubt an einen behörden
irrtum und legt einspruch ein
geduldig erklärt er sein auto fahre doch
emissionsfrei und dass es sich um ein e
fahrzeug handelt sieht doch eigentlich
jede politesse es steht an einer
stromtankstelle und hängt an einem
meterlangen ladekabel außerdem steht auf
dem kennzeichen auch noch ein deutliches
in leipzig ist das anscheinend egal denn
aus dem rathaus kommt post zwar nicht
die höchststrafe doch man brummt ihm ein
verwarnungsgeld von irrwitzigen 25 euro
auf
kein unrechtsbewusstsein im gegenteil
ich fühle mich sogar richtig gut dabei
bin ich mit dem auto in die stadt
leipzig fahrer und eben nicht zum
beispiel mit einem stinkenden diesel
viele leipziger bürger sehen es genauso
ich dachte einfach herzhaft darüber dass
die bürokratie für die wir deutschen so
berühmten des echten witz hagen kunde
benötigt also zwingend eine
feinstaubplakette
während qualmende oldtimer oder rußende
traktoren die es nicht brauchen kann das
ernsthaft sein
ja heißt es aus dem leipziger rathaus
genau so stehe es im gesetz eine für den
bürger gegebenenfalls besser
nachvollziehbare grundsätzliche lösung
kann daher nur vom gesetzgeber
geschaffen werden
die stadt leipzig hat ihren
diesbezüglichen handlungsspielraum im
vorliegenden einzelfall in korrekter
ermessensausübung genutzt
die leipziger bürger verstehen da weder
den gesetzgeber noch die stadtverwaltung
es ist eigentlich quatsch dass die
regelung kompletter blödsinn ist hat man
nun auch in berlin erkannt man will sie
demnächst ändern aber hand kunzes 25
euro sind futsch wohl oder übel hat er
sein auto nun für fünf euro
plaketten technisch aufgerüstet und kann
jetzt ganz entspannt durch leipzig düsen